so there's a foot on the moon it's been
nearly 50 years since Neil Armstrong
took those historic steps on the moon
and to help mark the moon landings
golden anniversary next year
Armstrong's family is auctioning off
items from the late astronauts personal
collection of memorabilia todd Imhoff is
the executive vice president for
heritage auctions Neil Armstrong and his
family had these items in their
possession for decades and they were
great stewards of those pieces they very
generously donated and loaned certain
items to various museums over those
years and now his sons have decided that
the time has come to share these items
and sell them and to the space
collecting community the 3,000 item
auction includes one of Armstrong's
project Gemini spacesuits and a gold pin
he wore on his first voyage into space
also up for bidding are items that
accompanied Armstrong on the Apollo 11
mission a Centennial flag from his alma
mater Purdue University and fragments of
the wing and propeller from the Wright
brothers first successful airplane the
auction also includes personal items
like this crayon drawing Armstrong
created as a first grader in 1936 and
his Boy Scout cap this weekend's release
of the new film biography first man
starring Ryan Gosling as Armstrong
should only help to boost sales
we need to Bale down here and so we
don't fail up there I think that
interest in the film and renewed
interest in Neil Armstrong's days as an
astronaut could very well spur more
interest in his artifacts and
memorabilia that the family is selling
I'm really surprised it's taken this
long for a feature film about Neil arm
about Neil Armstrong it's if that's a
really good point actually I'm very
excited to see that movie this auction
by the way runs from November 1st to
November 3rd I think there's gonna be a
lot of interest oh yeah